joining us now on stage is january
littlejohn the mom whose lawsuit kind of
served as the catalyst for this parental
rights movement and tina de sacovich
who's the co-founder of moms for liberty
um january tell us what happened with
your teenage child that kicked this all
off
sure
the pandemic was hard on many
adolescents and at the height of the
pandemic our daughter came and told us
that she was confused about her sex
this is becoming more and more common
and this was after three of her friends
in her in-person peer group at school
also had come out as transgender
and so after many weeks of
school had just started
my daughter got in the car and said mama
had a meeting with three school
officials and they asked me which
restroom i wanted to use
i immediately called the school
i was told i cannot be given any
information about the meeting because my
daughter was now protected by a
non-discrimination law essentially
protected from me they presume me to be
a danger to my child so you're the
danger to the child
and they're
what many are calling grooming the child
we have an update apparently from your
lawyer who's in the crowd
[Music]
where is he right here tell us
sure so we after he files our lawsuit
predictably the school district filed a
motion to dismiss we have filed an
opposition to that and we're waiting on
the ruling but what's more important
is that we are hearing the same exact mo
of excluding and deceiving parents um
exactly what we heard here from parents
literally around the country but the
good news is that parents are fighting
back and they're filing lawsuits in
states all around the country and here
in florida governor not only are parents
protected by the united states
constitution but they're protected by
the parent bill of rights and the
parents rights and education law that
you signed into law thank you
you know it all reminds me of when you
go to the pediatrician and then the
pediatrician says oh can you step out of
the room when you're when you're with
your child and the like uh yeah no we're
not doing that and they just assume that
parents will say oh yeah you can take my
child you can you can talk to my child
outside my presence no
now tina i want you to listen to biden's
disturbing remarks
on whom he believes your kids belong to
we always talk about these children
they're not someone else's children
there are children
they're all our children they're not
somebody else's children they're like
viewers when they're in the classroom
tina
they're not
they're not yours when they're in the
classroom apparently they're the
education establishments aka the
teachers unions
your reaction to that the president of
the united states on parental rights
laura it's outrageous i gave birth to my
children i carried them in my womb i
changed their diapers i nurse them they
are my children every mother knows that
it's their children it is unacceptable
that president biden or anybody in the
teachers union or anyone else would say
that they are collectively someone
else's child or collectively their
children they're they're a group you
know they're part of the community it's
a giant commune of a of an education
establishment and by the way biden
wasn't done with that because governor
he appeared to kind of take a pot shot
at you yesterday check it out
today there are too many politicians
trying to score political points trying
to
ban books
even math books do you ever think we'd
be teaching you're going to be worrying
about book burnings and banning books
all because it doesn't fit somebody's
political agenda
we've got to stop making the target of
the culture wars
uh governor they love the culture wars
when they were kicking god out of the
classroom but suddenly they're upset
because uh i guess you didn't want
political indoctrination in something as
simple as a math textbook
talk about that well we draw a very
strong line in florida we want education
we do not want indoctrination and that
means
and the reason why we we believe that is
because the parents have a fundamental
role in the upbringing and the education
and well-being of their kids and i think
biden and his folks believe you send
them to school butt out and the school's
job is to indoctrinate what they think
your kid should learn or what your kid
should believe and so this is a huge
debate in our country it's sad that it
is why would you want not want parents
involved but they don't want parents
involved because they know that will
represent an obstacle to them
indoctrinating them the way they want to
do that well january what you hear from
the main so-called mainstream media is
that this is an attack
on children on on children who identify
differently and that this is a
mean-spirited piece of legislation
whether it's a parental rights bill or
any of the textbooks and they try to
turn it against i think moms and dads of
all political persuasions who just
reading writing and arithmetic some
history would be nice that's fair um but
it's an attack on children your reaction
to that
that's absolutely false this is about
protecting children
because it is so critical to have
parents involved in every aspect of a
child's education
they have carved out this caveat
to presume parents to be an enemy but
only in this one area and it's
ridiculous and it's a false narrative
being used to drive a wedge in between
the parent-child relationship this is
fundamentally about protecting children
and making sure
parents are not cut out of critical
decisions being made at schools without
them well i know governor you did the
the the bill about you know k or pre-k
through three why'd you stop at three
that's like well it does and i mean it
says anything above that's got to be
developmentally and age appropriate so
the florida department of education will
be putting some meat on the bones would
you be potentially looking at looking at
limitations
at all here's the thing i mean things
like woke gender ideology have no place
in the schools
i mean if you want
if you want woke gender ideology then
go to oberlin or berkeley or something
like that but it's just not appropriate
we got to do math and and science and
reading and also but what we also did in
addition to parents rights education we
did curriculum transparency in florida
every parent has the right to know what
is being taught and the books that are
being used and they have a right to
protest and they don't like it if they
don't follow state standards they don't
want the parents to know what's going on
well because they want math textbooks
that have
leftist ideology in the math it's like
you know math is math okay it's not
about your feelings it's not about all
these other extraneous things and we
have to keep our eye on the prize here i
have to attend to my feelings of my
sponsors thank you january and tina hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else